i'm calling you right now from a windows
10 computer what is going to be
different when i upgrade to windows 11.
i would say the
experience right it's modern and more
importantly it's centered on you
even just that little subtle shift of
this start in the center
center center centered sent centered
centered around you
there it is from the king of microsoft
himself in windows 11 the company's next
big operating system due out later this
year
the start button moves to the bottom
center
[Music]
but that cosmetic change actually has
deeper meaning
the word center is core to satya
nadella's vision that windows 11 should
be at the center of your digital life
as apple and google entice users to
increasingly closed off worlds
he wants windows 11 to be a compelling
choice
for people who don't want to live
exclusively in either
windows has a role to play as that most
open
of ecosystems today that plays nicely
with in fact the others we want you to
be able to connect your phones
to your pcs we want you to be able to
communicate to people on phones or other
pcs
the proof is in the features windows 11
can now run
android apps to learn more about the new
software microsoft gave me an exclusive
interview with the company's ceo and
chairman i know there's like a new start
sound and i wanted to know if you could
do an impression of it no i wish i was i
need more talent
i took away three things the company is
doing in this new operating system
to lure users and app makers number one
a new modern interface those who
remember windows 8 know that messing
with the start menu before
didn't work out so well for microsoft
there's not somebody's job at microsoft
which is
how should we move the start button
where should we move it i'm sure it is
as well and we'll always also have the
option with windows as you know we'll
always have the option for anybody to go
back to whatever classic mode they want
but the placement is only part of the
fresh start click the button itself and
you get your apps
but also cloud connected recommendations
of what you might need next
the design system of windows is about
you
getting to your apps your files your the
people you want to connect with
faster with less friction there are lots
of other interface and design
changes this button on the taskbar
brings up a widget screen where you can
view all sorts of news and quick glance
information
hover on the maximize window button and
you get a tool to help you place
multiple windows side by side
these screenshots provided by microsoft
were taken on pre-release software
and the features are not final tell me
what kind of role did the pandemic play
in in the development of windows 11.
we definitely were influenced by the
need
for a modern operating system in some
sense the original idea of windows
has suddenly become again in 2021 a huge
priority
one of those pandemic driven features a
universal mute button
that lives in the system tray so you
don't always have to go digging whatever
video
calling app to mute yourself i'm very
into it
the second thing a new store with
android apps
we're going to welcome all apps across
even all the different application
platforms in windows itself right it can
be a pwp or a web app it can be
a native app and we're going to support
android as first class as well
all right tech translation up until now
the microsoft store was just for certain
kinds of windows apps
now it will be open for any windows app
but the real headline microsoft is
partnering with amazon's android app
store
tell me a little bit about what you're
doing with the microsoft store on
windows 10
and and specifically they're what you're
doing with amazon in fact you can go to
our store
search find an android application and
then
you know you'll be linked into the
amazon store and you can use the amazon
store apps
as if there are windows apps and all of
the windowing will work
it's a big move and one clearly aimed at
chromebooks
which also run android apps in the last
year unit sales of chromebooks grew by
275
windows 11 will also enable more windows
apps to run on new laptops and desktops
powered by arm mobile chips from
qualcomm
if you think about the traditional role
of operating systems operating systems
are very much
you know needed whenever there is a real
change in the system architecture right
i mean you think about the ai
chips now right it's not just the cpu
and the gpu but now npus are all
becoming part of
any pc another translation all these
parts of the chipset have changed in big
ways in the last few years to make
computers
smarter and more power efficient windows
11 will work better with them
and that brings us to the third a focus
on openness
why windows why should someone get
windows over chrome
over mac os windows gives you the most
choice of systems to apps
to everything that you want to be able
to do i think windows
in fact is becoming increasingly the
device that bridges
all of these ecosystems do you think of
yourself as sort of the switzerland
there of the ecosystems
i think that more than when we say
switzerland i think there are certain
platform rules by which we are
principally dry
windows i'm not saying that other
ecosystems shouldn't have their own
platform rules we have a different set
of platform rules and those platform
rules
i believe in 2021 are more needed than
they ever were
how are your platform rules different
than than say apple
one simple thing we have the ability
to have multiple marketplaces that can
thrive we want to have a great
marketplace but we also welcome other
marketplaces
we want to have great tools like say
teams
but we also welcome zoom or slack or
anything else to be also first
class apple's ios specifically does not
allow for third-party app stores
and has been the focus of recent
anti-trust scrutiny so if you have an
android phone it works
great with windows what about the iphone
we would love to make sure that it works
better i mean we do everything we can
like anything that apple wants to do
with windows whether it's itunes or
imessage or what have you
we would welcome that but overall we
want to make sure our software runs
great on apple devices and
windows works well with any software
from anyone whether it's google or apple
or adobe or anyone
but what mr nadella's biggest challenge
seems to be moving ahead without
alienating those who love windows of
yore
i want to read you something you said in
your first event as microsoft ceo and
this was in 2014 you said
this business does not respect tradition
what it respects is innovation on a go
forward basis
so it's really our collective challenge
that we now need to make microsoft
thrive
in a mobile first in a cloud-first world
how do you innovate with avoiding a
disaster
like windows 8. it's all about sort of
the batting average at the end of it all
the factored here
35 years after its inception and there's
no innovation that's risk-free
so let's say that and then um
and then you know boldly go forward but
don't worry you can still move your
start button to where it's always been
11 it's a big number it's a lucky a
lucky number 11 is a lucky number
oh it is a lucky number two ones make
eleven two ones make eleven
also add up to two there you go